las vegas man still on the ground in
ukraine doing whatever he can now to
protect children who are in his care now
we first introduced you to mark davis a
few weeks ago he runs abundance
international a non-profit that houses
orphans across the country as the
violence does intensify he and others
have worked harder to keep those kids
safe sasha loftis joins us tonight with
an update on his story sasha denise and
brian mark tells me since we first spoke
everything has changed he's now helping
refugees escape while he makes sure the
children that can't leave ukrainian soil
survive
we did not really believe it was going
to come to this two weeks ago the world
flipped upside down for mark davis and
the children he cares for in ukraine you
can't explain to an infant what war is
he's a las vegas native but lives
overseas to run abundance international
a nonprofit that houses orphans across
the country
since russia's invasion on february 24th
this is where those children are living
in bomb shelters as fighting continues
in their home cities of mikalive and
kirsan
which davis says is now mainly
controlled by russian forces we can't do
anything for them i can't get past the
tanks and into russian territory to
bring supplies mark tells us he's done
everything he can to keep himself and
others safe
but wants people in the valley to know
there are ways to make a difference i
want to be that conduit that bridge
between people whose hearts are here and
giving them a chance to actually do
something real every donation or offer
to help kids get the supplies they need
makes the hardest of times just a little
bit brighter amazing things are
happening among the darkness
so far mark tells me all the children in
his organization's care are safe but he
believes they have a long road ahead of
them if you'd like to help we have more
information on our website
8newsnow.com brian